et le fait que eric naulleau à nîmes
c'est évidemment pour les
téléspectateurs comme pour nous les
autres chroniques un une différence de
quand c'est toi cyril ça n'a strictement
rien à voir alors lui il a dit
il va être l'anti mélenchon primaire bon
il a le droit donc en tant
qu'intellectuel citoyens d'être anti
mélenchon primaire le problème c'est que
quand il est animateur il faut qu'il
fasse avec tout le tour de table y
compris avec une personne qui
effectivement est proche de la france en
effet musicale pardon excusez moi mais
enfin alors vous êtes aussi c'est quand
même être bien positionné pour donner
mon impression bien sûr que quand tu
animé l'émission mais ces deux séries
exactement et moi avec eric que souvent
on est opposée sur plein d'idées moi je
m'oppose tous les joueurs à zemmour donc
de dire qu'il veut pas d'opposants à
zemmour sur le plateau déjà c'est un
mensonge puisque j étais fière et je
pense que je porte justement mes valeurs
chaque jour contre lui déjà on peut
rétablir sa mais laraque elle tu ne te
rends pas compte le comportement que tu
as commencé dès détestable pour nous
tous parce que tu saccage l'émission je
vais te le dire avec mon coeur la
semaine dernière c'était effroyable
parce que tu t'en prends à lui parce que
ça te gêne qu'ils soient animateurs
peut-être botul être à sa place je ne
sais pas tu l'as déjà expliqué et tu ne
peux pas prendre en otage notre émission
à tous on est une équipe tous les gens
qui produisent derrière tous les gens
qui quittent s'occupe de nous et saccagé
l'émission je te jure on ne savait pas
où se mettre parce que tu te les prix
mis en tête et tout à coup ça a été un
fût d'accusation c'est un plateau
d'extrême droite on ne parlait que des
moore et c'est déjà cette mode de
toujours commenté pourquoi on choisit un
sujet ou l'autre c'est insupportable
c'est pas à nous de dire pourquoi on
soyez un sujet ou l'autre c'est des
sujets d'actualité et ensuite de dire
qu' est-ce que tu l'a suggéré là parce
qu'il ya des gens qui sont plus à droite
maintenant sur le plateau et alors en
fait vous êtes pour la censure à la
france est soumise tu dis qui censure
mais c'est vous qui censure et vous
voulez pas des gens de droite vous
voulez pas des gens tu veux black blanc
beur et puis bon c'est malheureux c'est
bon c'est bon alors ans après je vous
dis c'est vrai qu'aussi et j'aurais
peut-être dû vous en parler à tous les
chroniqueurs de btp c'est vrai que
j'aurais dû peut-être faire une petite
réunion en disant voilà en expliquant
que c'est ricky à la nuit voilà je vais
revenir nos balances ton post également
jeu en animé je vous dis pas mal des
cours on prendra donc je vais vraiment
animé pas mal de balances ton post aussi
mais c'est vrai que j'aurais peut-être
dû dire voilà c'est eric qui va prendre
ma place et j'aurais peut-être bu vous
en parlait tous en même temps voilà
c'est peut-être ça aussi ça le fait non
mais le fait de masse éditorialistes
animateur principal aussi voilà
peut-être que voilà il y en a qui l'ont
ils n'ont ils ont ils ont mal perçu
après dire eric naulleau j'ai dû revenir
sur le sujet eric c'est que voilà ce que
vous reprochez eric et c'est que eric et
animateur mais il est aussi militant
pour vous c'est à dire qu'il donne trop
son avis sur les sujets si son style
d'animation qu'est ce que vous dites ah
ça non mais moi j'aurai convenu qu'on
revienne sur le véritable problème le
problème on l'a vu sur les images les
voisins raquel ils n'en peuvent plus tu
vois la tête de renard julien courbet tu
vois tu vois la tête de karim zéribi il
est accablé il ya une migraine qui monte
il a fini par te le dire moi j'ai quand
même le souvenir de d'un certain cyril
hanouna qui était animateur il lui
arrivait que tu lui fasse péter les
plombs si on a vu des choses je ne
trahis pas des secrets puisque c'était à
moitié en plateau à moitié en dehors du
plateau